so let's start with this purpose is not
passion they're related but they're not
the same thing passion is also not that
hard to figure out neither is purpose
people just have not been given the
right tools so let's simplify it for you
today and if you're someone who's
struggling to figure out what your
purpose and your passion are this video
is going to be insanely helpful for you
I have a who why how process who is your
most important core value we're not
going to dive into that in this video
but the next two are your why and your
how your why is your purpose and your
how is your passion so let's start with
purpose your purpose is your why your
purpose comes from your pain your
purpose is whatever the thing you
struggled with the most in life think
back to the most painful moment in your
life what was it what was happening what
was around you what was that moment for
positive entrepreneur optimistic people
this actually might be a challenge for
me it was a challenge because I don't
want to think about the bad past I don't
think about what happened to me I'm
focused on what I'm doing now and going
forward not rear view mirror stuff what
happened back then doesn't matter except
it does because the thing that will fill
you up the most is helping people who
are currently going through the the
thing that you struggled with the most
need motivation what's your top 10 with
believe Nation hey this is Nina Karma
Karma lack of believe in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something so get ready to know
you why and how expect the hard times
and trust your vision with my husband
Evan Carmichael and his top 10 rules for
success
so whatever was the most painful moment
in your life from when you're born until
right now that you can remember not
physical pain psychological pain mental
pain the thing that made you feel
terrible what was that thing
your purpose is to help other people who
are feeling that right now
and so imagine who you are now and
imagine who you used to be whether
that's a year ago five years ago 10
years ago go back to whoever that person
was let's just say it's five years ago
great the person you are now can help
the person who you were five years ago
you may not have all the answers you're
still on your path you don't know
everything but you've grown you've
you've come out of the hole you're
better than you were five years ago
talk to the person you were five years
ago helping that person is your purpose
you've climbed up the staircase right
you've grown there's still a lot more
stairs to grow you don't want the
staircase to end that staircase is your
growth is your professional and personal
development for life you want to keep
climbing and every time you take a step
what you want to do is reach down and
help somebody else up but you can only
help people to the extent that you've
grown if taken eight steps on the
staircase that's all you can help people
up to get to step number eight
you get to 20 you can help people more
so we want to keep growing keep climbing
those stairs and then keep reaching back
and pulling people up and giving them a
hand that's your purpose for Life you'll
you'll like serving people and helping
people and it's tied to your core value
your who your one word we're not talking
about it much in this video but you'll
just like helping people because service
is hardwired into our brain helping
people is hardwired to your brain it has
a similar impact on your brain as food
and sex it's hardwired you'll like it
you want to help people you want to
serve but who you serve will be
different it'll have a different impact
I love helping people in general but if
you're an entrepreneur that's something
extra special there's so many great
causes in the world there's so many
great causes why this instead of this
because you have an emotional connection
to it an emotional attachment to it why
because you went through it
because you suffered through it and you
want to make sure that nobody else has
to suffer as much as you suffered your
purpose comes from your pain period
it'll fill you up for Life helping
entrepreneurs will fill me up for the
rest of my life it will never get old
when I'm tired when I have no energy
when I'm depleted I will still meet with
entrepreneurs because it fills me up
your purpose comes to your pain you have
to find it now let's talk about passion
so your passion is your how your passion
is the things that you're doing how
you're going to actually execute against
your why execute against your purpose
what are you doing it's great that you
believe an entrepreneur is amazing but
what are you going to do how are you
going to go about doing it so for me
it's making videos for me it's doing
speaking gigs for me it's writing books
for me it's helping people one-on-one
for me it's doing events right that's my
how
but that will evolve that will change
right I started doing this helping
entrepreneur thing when I was 22 years
old and that started just by doing
speaking and then it became my website
and I had a hundred thousand plus pages
of content and then I shut the thing
down overnight and I focused on YouTube
and it's been a 10 year plus Journey on
YouTube and and maybe in 10 years that's
gone and I'm doing something totally
different I don't know the how will
change a lot
what you get passionate about or to
Mel's point about energy what you get
energy about will change with time but
it has to be connected to your purpose
just because it gives you energy it's
not going to fill you up it's got to be
connected to a deeper source which is
your purpose rule number two expect
tween outstand
s what you do when it gets hard people
with an average mindset only do things
when it's easy because it's easy anyone
can do it but life is coming for you
setbacks they're coming for you and
that's what separates the average from
the outstanding your goals they don't
count until it's hard so I had a new guy
on my team who's writing to me to say
Evan super important this is urgent I
need help with my schedule I'm just not
seeing consistent I'm not staying on my
goals I know what I want to get done for
you but also for my life and and it's
not unless it's some deadline or you're
on me it's not happening I'm not
consistent on it how do how do I get
going how do I stay consistent
and so we work together through the
schedule and we created his calendar and
say what are your goals and put it in
your calendar and how do you want each
day to go and he plotted out his
Saturday to Sunday you know the whole
week and then I asked him okay now put
in your morning routine what do you want
to do every day right so we plotted that
into his calendar and now he's got this
weekly schedule of what he's going to do
every morning and then every day doing
different things and how he wants his
ideal life to go awesome
and then I told him what really mattered
like this is great your actions have to
your Ambitions really important
but following through in your calendar
doesn't count until it's hard
maybe maybe today is going to be easy
for you maybe tomorrow's easy for you
because we talked because you're
motivated because you're inspired he's
like yeah yeah I'm gonna go do it
awesome what happens when you don't
sleep well what happens when something
happens in your family what happens when
the website crashes what happens when
something happens what happens when
you've lost some motivation energy what
happens when you get some bad news what
happens what do you do this is where
most people crumble
this is where most people as soon as
this one little tiny thing that
interrupts them they're gone they fall
off their entire schedule and routine
your goals suddenly don't matter anymore
you don't think they're possible
your goals don't count until they're
hard that's what I told them I said
listen listen to me
this is a great plan
that life that you wrote that's a great
life what you wrote down on your
calendar that's a great life for you
that's what you want
imagine if you did that every day for
the next year how different would your
life look like one year from today if
you were consistent on staying like oh
yeah yeah amazing I mean great doesn't
count until it's hard none of this
matters until it's hard life is coming
for you get ready
and what I want him and I want you to
realize is that
you need to expect it because you're
working your calendar and it's great and
here we go we're getting our getting our
objectives and going for our goals and
then when something hits Us in the face
you're surprised by it
you're shocked
and then you fall off course don't be
surprised expect it expect the
difficulty expect the road bump expect
somebody to punch you in the face like
expected it's coming
and this is your chance to be
outstanding
because everybody else is going to be
average rule number three trust your
vision the reason why you don't follow
through on your vision is because you
don't trust it enough it makes sense
that it's going to happen but it's not
happening yet people aren't saying yes
there's no momentum there's no money
coming in and you start to wonder who am
I to have this big dream so then there's
this temptation to give up and go do
something else and not follow through on
your vision but you know in the back of
your head you know you know that
eventually for someone it's gonna work
out you need to stay on it you need to
follow through otherwise someone else is
going to make money off of your idea
they're gonna make it happen without you
so I look at what I'm trying to do here
with with this Channel with my YouTube
content with my my mission my purpose
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem I want to spread more belief
right the world's biggest problem is
that people don't believe in themselves
enough I think everybody is a genius
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something they're just not
living it they're not doing it they're
not expressed and so they end up living
a life that they don't like knowing that
they're capable of more like this is the
problem I am trying to solve it's one
that that I'm never going to fully solve
in my lifetime and I wake up every day
trying to do it and it's easy to get up
and think well there's so many people
trying to do the same thing there's
there's Tony Robbins and there's all
these other people who am I to go off
and do this and I remind myself that I
may not be Tony Robbins I may not ever
have as big an impact I may not sell as
many books as Simon signic I mean I may
never have that big an impact
but I was able to help some people
yeah we've have two million subscribers
across the channels we have 300 million
views across the channels it's having an
impact it's helping people
I can get better I need to get better
but what I'm doing is already having an
impact in helping people so I need to
keep going and that's what I find really
helpful just reminding yourself that
that you matter that the work you do
matters even if it hit one person it
made a difference it matters and so you
have to follow through rule number four
be your biggest critic and fan you need
to be your biggest critic as well as
your biggest fan people are usually
their biggest critics you point out all
the flaws you tell yourself all the
reasons why you suck I actually think
that's a good thing being your biggest
critic forces you to get better but it's
only healthy if it's paired with you
also being your biggest fan you think
that you suck but you also feel like
you're amazing like you're a gift to the
world like you're the best thing ever
you suck and you're amazing you're the
worst and you're the best both I think
that's a healthy balance you have to be
your biggest critic as well as your
biggest fan both at the same time also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after a while watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five push yourself to
the extreme people don't push themselves
to the extreme
they just don't
it's because it's too hard
it's too crazy hard
on your own and so I think when those
opportunities come learning to embrace
them learning to take them on learning
to say this is my chance
to show myself and the world what I am
made of this is my chance
but is it still your limit so let me
give you a couple examples this morning
I woke up and I didn't have a lot of
sleep I went to bed at three something
last night I woke up at 7 20 this
morning I turned off the alarm but still
woke up at 7 20. force a habit and I'm
not on a lot of sleep and I need to make
a bunch of videos for you guys and I
want to bring my best and I put pressure
in myself that every video needs to be
my best I want it to be better I want to
grow I don't want to just do the same
thing over and over and over again
but it's a challenge and so it's easy to
say oh I'm so tired I don't have energy
I I wish I slept more or an excuse after
excuse but no I'm gonna go do it and
here I am and I've made I don't know how
many videos are ready today I'm closing
in on finishing up and I still have
energy and I'm pumped for how it went
and in the story I'm telling myself is
I'm awesome like I had very little sleep
it's not how I want to be living every
day but when that happens what do you do
how do you stand up how do you show
yourself What You're Made Of
but even that is not the biggest extreme
you know like I feel like I'm capable of
way more my tour
was the most that I'd ever pushed myself
not just mentally not just facing fears
but physically physically pushing myself
where I broke my neck in two spots
um I had a concussion I've never had a
concussion before I was wild
don't wish anybody if you haven't
experienced it yet I had three Staples
in my head I compressed my spine it was
brutal
and I had to cancel my event in Denver
where I was because it was that night
and then the next one was going to be in
Kansas City this is what I wore for for
60 days I wore these and I took them off
for 10 minutes a day
60 days right like this is what I made
it this is what I'm capable of I'm
complaining about having four hours
sleep I did I had my neck broken and
continued on my tour
across the U.S for 30 more days and
another 30 days here in Toronto
seeing entrepreneurs sitting in pain at
the front of the room with ice packs and
pillows and not quitting and going home
even though I was in massive pain like
this is who I am and I'm complaining
about not having sleep the night before
right like perspective the greatest
point of the tour for me was in Kansas
City it was my next stop we refunded
everybody the money because I wasn't
going to be able to go for three hours
but I said hey we already booked this
hotel venue
you guys already booked your night off
why don't you just come out anyway just
come on out and I'll go for an hour and
take pictures and say hi and just show
some Kansas City love
and I showed up and we went for an hour
and a half and then my wife pulled me
off
because my lips are starting to get dry
because I wasn't being able to you know
answer questions at Clues I'd like
because I was still suffering from the
concussion you know the the neck pain is
one thing that's just sitting still I
can't do anything about it but the
concussion you're not supposed to think
you're not supposed to have uh
conversations it makes the recovery
worse
and so she's she was watching me like a
hawk the whole night she's watching me
and then she sees me start the Fate he's
like okay that's it I gotta take Evan
home quick pictures and we gotta go
I've never been pulled off a stage
before
never for like for sucking or definitely
for a physical issue never never it's
never happened
this was me at my physical limit
that was it I was done I had actually
nothing left like somebody had to come
and say you are done
[Music]
the best right
I mean it sucked but at the same time
it's like man this is it I actually I
got to the edge I got to the physical
limitation I can't go anymore I'm being
told I need to step down and there's
something so amazing that you feel about
yourself that you were able to go that
far now you don't want to do that every
day you want to take care of your health
of course of course of course don't
don't do stupid things
and at the same time the pride
the feeling of Awesomeness
that you hit
that Mark I can't explain so I started
telling the people around me my wife my
agent the people on the tour that were
planning the 2020 tour and it's not
going to be as good
this would be great so we're gonna hit
23 cities 90 days East Coast Texas
Mexico you know Montreal it's going to
be fun
but it won't be as good because I'm not
going to break my neck
right I'm not gonna hit I'm not gonna
forcefully go break my neck just because
right that's that that's stupid don't do
that don't don't don't go do that just
because and so I'm not gonna face the
same challenge
and so the point is I also have a great
time it'll still be amazing but what we
went through what I had to go through in
2019 this year is
foundational like
I'm gonna remember this forever this is
who I am this this this is who I am
not the guy who
thinks that four hours sleep and making
some videos is a big deal right
it just resets who you are and reminds
you if you step up to the challenge of
what you're capable of rule number six
ignore the bad advice the people who are
telling you that your idea won't work
are not the people whose life that you
want so why are you listening to them
your Uncle Joe your Aunt Susan the rest
of your family the people who you grew
up with from high school look at their
life look at their life right now take
away their words and what they're
telling you remove the emotion from it
look at their life do you want a life
like theirs because their advice will
lead to a life like theirs if not then
you probably should be doing the exact
opposite of what they're telling you to
do now I think there's two types of
people who will give you negative
feedback you got the haters and then you
got the people who are just ignorant and
there's a big difference between those
two so let's start with the haters the
haters I call the little man the haters
their entire role and their life is to
bring other people down maybe they took
their shot this is actually quite
frequent they took their shot they tried
they didn't work they failed and so now
nobody around them can be successful
they get their value they get their
self-love by destroying other people
because it makes them feel better about
themselves it's like watching some train
wreck on reality TV show right watching
relationships and lives fall apart
because it makes you feel better about
your life you feel better about your
life when you see somebody else's life
be a total mess right those are the
haters now how do you deal with them it
starts by understanding that
if you believe like I believe that
humans are built to serve right people
are built to serve you want to do good
people are good right both of those
things humans are good and we're built
to serve then what would get somebody
who is good and built to serve to leave
a nasty negative comment or to tell you
that you suck or your deal is not going
to work out what would drive them to
doing
they really hate their life
right like empathy is the first step
just feeling bad for them not not
sympathy and and using that as a
negative against them not saying well
your life sucks I'm not gonna that
that's not gonna help anything it's
actual genuine empathy if the highlight
of somebody's day is coming to this
video and leaving a negative comment
it's okay I feel bad for that person
if that's the highlight of your day then
you must be in a really rough spot if
you're if you believe that people are
good and they're built to serve and so
what that does is remove the sting out
of the comment when somebody is Raging
on you
that that you suck and that your idea is
never going to work having empathy to
understand wow this person is likely in
a really tough spot
that removes the Stinger of the words
and allows you to then be more
practical less emotional to respond
emotionally and feel like oh my God
maybe they're right maybe they have a
point maybe I do suck say wait wait a
minute wait a minute this person they
hate their life why am I listening to
them right just like the wake-up call
out of the the head game that you're in
listen to their advice so those are the
haters remove the sting and then allow
you to make a practical decision the
second part are the people who are
ignorant they're your friends your
family the people around you who they
actually love you right chances are your
parents love you your mom probably loves
you right most moms love their kids your
parents probably love you so why would
they be telling you not to go do
something why would why would they be
telling you advice against what you want
to hear
because they grew up in a different era
your parents are pilgrims your parents
don't understand a world that exists
your parents don't understand that you
can have a full-time business from this
it doesn't make sense when your parents
were your age they couldn't do the
things that you can do
so they want you to be successful the
people around you who love you want you
to be successful they have a different
definition of success
success to them looks different than it
does for you because they're from a
different era and that's okay again
starting point is empathy understand
that these words that are coming out of
their mouth is love they're trying to
express love their concerned for you
they want you to win they just have a
different version of what winning looks
like rule number seven do what you love
burnout is real but I think most burnout
happens because people are not doing the
thing that they actually love doing it's
not just about being busy and keeping
your mind occupied all day you can be
busy and hate your life and get burnt
out if I was an accountant I would hate
my life and burn out in a day because I
don't like being an accountant but doing
this thing that I love I put in way more
effort way more work and I love it it's
been 10 plus years of still having my
YouTube channel and I'm not burnt out if
anything I'm pushing harder than ever
before because I love it and so I think
it's not just about being busy it's
about being busy on the thing that is
your mission for life now compassion
fatigue is a thing doing it so much that
you burn out yourself is possible but
again that is not why most people are
burning out most people I believe are
burning out because they're spending too
much time too much energy too much
effort doing things that they hate and
if you wake up and hate your life and
hate the job you're about to go to then
there's no wonder why you feel like
you're burning out so I recently came
back from going to Tony Robbins event in
Dallas he invited me to sit in the front
row and uh super blessed and grateful to
have Tony support and I went there with
Alex friend of the channel who helps me
run trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because Alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there Alex
was flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a Tony
Robbins event it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever I travel
is actually meet believe Nation meet you
guys and so all through the event I wear
my believe hoodie and I'm not wearing
Grand stuff I'm wearing Evan Carmichael
stuff with the plane and the believe on
the back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience Tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning every
event saying hey I have some friends of
mine you might know them don't be
celebrities leave them alone don't talk
to them let them have their own
experience and it always makes me sad
when he says that because for me meeting
you guys meeting people who recognize me
and that's a group that I over index
because people who watch Tony videos you
know they're probably going to find my
content I like it I like it more when
people come and say hi it adds to the
experience for me and then on the last
day before we rushed out to go to the
airport I set up a meet-up right I had
an hour open before having to get to the
airport so let's do a meet up let's do a
local Dallas Richardson Texas Meetup
right and and it could have spent the
time doing something else or sleeping in
or writing my book or doing anything
else but
it's not burnout for me like that fuels
me that gives me more energy I love it
hanging out with believe Nation gives me
more energy than it takes away and I
then took an Uber to get to my to the
airport and the guy who drove the Uber
was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I got to start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
a total fluke but amazing and so it's a
lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one-hour meet up
because that hour was open and
it fuels me but if it was something that
I hated just that half an hour just 15
minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
this is terrible and so I think it's
really important that you're doing work
that you love that would be a burnout
for other people but not a burnout for
you because you love it so much really
you rarely regret the things that you do
it's what you don't do that you regret
the most it's all the missed
opportunities the times you wanted to
say yes but were afraid the moments that
you wanted to bet on yourself but you
were scared those moments that's what
you want to minimize because it's way
better to know and to fail than to never
know at all rule number nine do
difficult things self-confidence comes
from doing difficult things from trying
failing getting back up and trying again
a different way your goals don't count
until they're hard you won't make
yourself proud unless it's hard and it's
time to start making yourself proud of
your effort so I'm in the process of
writing a new book and I sent the book
out to 30 of my friends and friends of
friends to get their feedback and I'm a
crazy deadline with the publisher you
got I got it I gotta hear this is this
is the copy this is this is what I gave
out to 30 different people and
they gave me all the books back on the
same day and then what I had to do was
go through each copy and underline I
underlined can you see kind of blurry I
underlined anytime they underlined I
underlined because I wanted to see what
they cared about as well as catching
typos and everything else and I looked
at that pile of books I had 30 books I
had to get through in one day I had to
basically read my own book 30 different
times make one Master Copy underline it
the whole day and and it stressed me out
I looked at that stack of books and said
how am I gonna get through all this
stuff and I just started taking action I
just started doing it and here's the
thing halfway through I started getting
massive pain my neck was was really
hurting me my back was really hurting me
my neck mostly because I broke my neck
in March and I'm still healing and
recovering from it and I had to spend
the whole time
I had to spend the whole time like this
right I got the books here on the table
and flipping through it and I'm doing
this and takes a toll the whole day
doing it like this so a couple hours in
I'm having massive neck pain
[Music]
it's the best right like I gotta get
through it this is the time it doesn't
count until it's hard I don't want to be
doing this every single day right if
that's every day you need to change your
life you need to change your habits but
in those rare moments when you get the
chance to push yourself you either
physically mentally uh or just courage
because you're afraid of doing something
that's your chain so that's your chance
to show yourself What You're Made Of and
Rule Number 10 a very last one before
the bonus clip is serve humans are built
to serve period serving others is
hardwired into our brain it triggers the
same area of your brain as food and sex
if you're not happy it's because you're
not serving either serving the world on
this big mission that you have or
serving the 25 closest people to you if
you're not happy it's because you're not
serving so one of the hacks that I do in
my life to get me to do the things that
I'm afraid of or don't want to do is
through service if I can connect any of
my actions like making videos I don't
necessarily really like just sitting
here talking to a camera but I connected
to service that I'm making this video
people are going to watch it hopefully
they get inspired enough to take some
kind of action and it's meaningful to
their life or business that makes me
feel good that's Service as soon as I
can connect the action to service I am
all in and that's the way to hack me you
want something from me whether it's my
wife or my team or general public if it
makes me feel like this will serve other
people and it would have a big impact
then it's much easier for me to get a
yes it's easy for me to say I am in
My Philosophy on losing is you either
win or you learn you win you got your
goal hey hey congratulations pat
yourself on the back well you learn you
learned how not to do it again hopefully
you've improved and you've gotten better
it's only a loss if you quit it's only a
lot of you never get back up it's only a
loss if you stop trying somebody asked
me on my Instagram yesterday I love this
business that I'm doing but it's just
not working out what do I do
and my answer is hey if you still love
it you have to keep going
you have to keep trying you have to keep
getting up you have to keep not just
doing the same thing you've been doing
you have to keep looking exploring
trying new ways you have to have to have
to have to keep going because if you
stop now if you love the thing and you
stop now you will regret that decision
for the rest of your life
how many times have you quit on
something that you loved and then you
look back you say I wish I what if I
just kept going what if I just tried one
more day what if I just tried one more
week what if I just kept going because I
would have been in a different spot
and now regret not trying
if you don't love it great quit I mean I
think people stain things for too long
as well people stay in businesses for
too long people staying relationships
for too long out of fear out of
insecurity the love was gone a long time
ago and you should have left a long time
ago but you're too afraid to do it
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about what you love doing and it
hasn't worked out yet you have to keep
going
when I
was in my first business that this is
the thing that really helped me I was 19
years old I wanted to quit on my
business I was struggling I was making
no money 300 bucks a month I own 30 of a
company that was not making any money
and I was working every day and I just
had enough I had enough I was fed up
like how much further can I go how much
longer can I go and just not see money
and not see results and
I felt like I was a pretty happy
optimistic positive guy but it just
every day it just beat me down a little
bit more a little bit more a little bit
more and I was too embarrassed and
ashamed to tell people so it's all by
myself and I quit on my business partner
it was the worst day of my life
and the thing that kept me going
was the fear of regret
that this is not a loss unless I quit
this is not really a loss unless I
actually throw in the towel and go do
something else because I still wanted it
to work in my heart of hearts I still
love this thing I wanted to do something
with it it just I was quitting because I
wasn't getting the results yet
and what I told myself from 19 almost
20. was when when I'm an old man at 40
. you know I'm 40 how old am I now I'm
41 right now so it's funny thinking
about it but when I'm an old man at 40
and my life is over and and I hate my
life and it's it and I'm falling apart I
will regret this I will regret that I
quit
and that feeling
gave me the courage
to go one more day to say I I can't quit
yet this is not I have not given it
everything that I've got I have not left
it all out on the field right there's
still more in me to give to serve the
help there's more effort
but what it did was
forced me to start to think differently
because I couldn't keep going the way I
was going because what I was doing
obviously was not working every idea
that I tried was not working I needed to
think of something radically different
and that's where the idea of modeling
success came in for me it was finally
out of desperation not out of
inspiration not out of mentorship not
anything else not a genius wasn't that
smart it was out of desperation that I
asked myself who else has built a
software company before I cannot be the
first guy to have tried to do this
there's no way somebody has figured this
out like who's done this
and by modeling Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft that started the path
for my company to start to have success
in a short amount of time I closed my
first deal it was 13 and a half thousand
dollars I felt like I was rich on top of
the world and it gave me momentum it
gave me hope and it also gave me a
strategy that I could keep using
so if you have lost recently
there's two key ways that you need to
get out of it
okay the first is emotional
and then the second is strategy logical
that the emotional part is you feel hurt
you feel
scared you feel hopeless you feel
insecure you feel like it it this will
never work it may never work all these
people may be relying on you hopefully
nobody saw you fail we're just afraid of
this judgment and disappointing people
feel like you're not valuable
feel like you're wasting your time
and so the way to get through the
emotional pain
is one to focus on regret that if you
love this thing
and you quit now you will regret this
whether it's 10 years in the future 20
years in the future 30s in the future
you don't want to think back like I had
that shot back then I had that shot and
I didn't take it and I quit too soon
like don't let that be you
fear of regret and the second is service
that you're not doing this just for you
that there's people who are struggling
and they need your help they need your
support there's people who will be
counted on you that your story can
Inspire other people as well
and so sometimes you need the the hug
which is service and sometimes you need
to push which is regret
depending on where you're at what you're
feeling but when you lose
there are lots of logical strategic
practical ways to get out but if you
don't solve the emotional issue first
you'll stay stuck
so it's the emotional issue you have to
deal with first
that just because you lost doesn't mean
that you are a loser as a human right
just because your business hasn't worked
out yet doesn't mean that you as a
person have no self-worth your business
might not have any worth yet but it
doesn't mean that you have no worth and
that's that's something that took me a
long time to be able to separate out
that you are not your business
you are amazing you are gifted you are
talented you are loved you want to
contribute you want to serve and then
you bring that to your business not that
you are your business
once you solve the the emotional side
then you can work to the Practical side
then you can think about okay how do I
how do I solve this problem how do I
break out of this rut that I'm facing
and one of my favorite ways now is
modeling success right find the person
who's done the thing that's why I make
so many videos that's why I profile so
many different entrepreneurs and
athletes and coaches and experts because
maybe the way Oprah Winfrey says it or
Tim Grover says it or Steve Jobs says it
or whoever maybe the way they say it
finally starts to land finally starts to
seep in to give you the idea that you
need to then explode your business
forward
you first start with the emotional side
and solve that
that you are here to serve you are
valuable and that you will regret
quitting on this thing if you quit too
soon and then you can move the tactics
and strategies just like I did with my
business
I quit I quit on my partner
and said I'm done I need to feel
valuable as a human
and realize the next day I leaned in
more on the regret I do not want to live
with regret and being old men at 40 and
look back and say this was my moment
and then that led to the strategy the
Practical side to say okay but I can't
keep going how I'm going how do I solve
this problem okay modeling success
it's only a loss if you quit
it's only a loss if you stay down
it's only a loss if you tell yourself
that you suck and that will it will
never work out
you either win or you learn
the choice is yours
the get back up to learn the lessons
that you learned and to take another
shot because your goals matter because
your dreams matter because the thing
you've got inside your heart right here
can have a huge impact on the world and
we need to get the message out be the
change you want to see in the world
one of my favorite quotes Mahatma Gandhi
if you're not happy with something
you're not happy with a situation you
fix it that's why entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the problems
not as much as the government and big
business I think it's entrepreneurs it's
us we're going to solve all the world's
problems because we see a problem and we
want to fix it we want to solve it
that's what we do that's the most
exciting part of being an entrepreneur
is that you're not waking up and driving
to some job that you hate where the work
you're doing does not matter has no
meaning and instead you get to do
something that is actually going to
touch somebody's life and that is
Meaningful to you right you get the pick
you get to decide you get to choose and
we're trying to make the world a better
place we're going to make money doing it
too but Mission first purpose first and
then making money along the way in
service of others and it's in that
combination of what you love doing with
what brings value to other people that
you have a successful business
part of that then becomes being a leader
as well and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle with being the
leader because at the beginning
we are just managing ourselves and
that's hard enough right it's like have
you had a hard time managing yourself
have you had a hard time sticking to
your routines and keeping to your
motivation and staying strong and the
things that you say you're going to do
like self-management self-leadership is
hard enough now we're going to go off
and lead other people as well and where
do we learn about leadership we don't go
to school for this we don't have
programs we don't probably have great
mentors to help us if you had jobs in
the past or maybe you're at a job right
now you probably don't have the greatest
leaders around you most people suck at
it
but it doesn't have to be
extremely difficult
and it took me a long time to get used
to it and get better at it and I'm still
learning and improving we've got almost
40 people on the team now and can people
ask me what's my definition my
definition of leadership it's I want
people to win
more than I want them to win with me
and so the key becomes
wanting the humans that are on your team
to win as humans
more than you want them to win with you
that you can have this little
disconnection obviously they have to do
the work if they're going to work with
you but sometimes the best thing for
them to do is to move on
not because they're not doing their job
but because it's the best thing for them
and so when I connect with the people on
my team it's always trying to figure out
where do they want to go what do they
want to learn what do they what do they
want to improve on and I see everybody
as running parallel paths with me so the
people around you the people even us
right now what we're doing right now
this is a parallel path you've decided
to watch this video I decided to record
this video and we're sharing this moment
in time and maybe you never watch
another Evan Carmichael video again
maybe you end up watching all my videos
and we end up being Partners on some
future business who knows you know I've
even seen you every day in the future
but as of right now we're on this
parallel path together and
when somebody's with you walking down
that parallel path
the goal of a great leader I think
should be to try to make that person
leave better than how they came in
right have have you ever heard the
expression
um my grandfather used to tell me about
you know when you go to a hotel
or you go to a new city or you go to a
new event they always try to leave the
place better than when you came
you know and hopefully that's our goal
for life you know in this life we try to
leave
the world a little better than how it
was when we came in
and so if you take that approach to
leadership that when you're with the
people on your team
and maybe it's for a week on some really
short internship maybe it's for a year
maybe it's for five years ten years
maybe it's their entire life with you
that they have left a little bit better
than when they came in because they got
to hang around you and not taking it as
an ego play like I'm gonna make this
person's life better because I am so
amazing it's more out of care
genuine care
for the people on your team and I think
when we're first hiring
we suck at it
most entrepreneurs suck at hiring most
entrepreneurs their first employee is
not with them you know a year two years
three years later because they hired the
wrong person they have no idea how to
manage that person it's not that that
person sucks it's more that you know you
don't have the skill set we don't have
the skill sets at the beginning to know
how to even find the right person let
alone manage them and so
you know we that's the skill that we
have to develop but I think it just
starts with genuinely caring about the
people on your team that yes they have
to get the work done right there's a job
that has to get done but how we often
think about it is more from a selfish
perspective as I need to get this stuff
off my plate right you're overloaded
with work right who's over are you
overloaded with work for overloaded with
work
so I gotta hire somebody to take this
off my plate so I don't have to deal
with that ever again and it frees up my
time to go and do other stuff
right so familiar listen at the
beginning when you bring on team it
takes more time
it takes more time than it frees up
because you have to train them you have
to listen to them you have to care for
them you have to answer their questions
if you treat them like a robot or a
monkey
they're not going to stick with you
you're going to constantly be hiring and
firing and hiring firing you're going to
be massively frustrated and overwhelmed
and a lot of a lot of entrepreneurs get
stuck in that cycle where has this
happened to you you hire somebody you
know looks great on paper you're so
excited for it to go and then it doesn't
work out a couple months later and then
you decide that you know what I'm just
gonna do it all myself right I know I
can get it done I'm just gonna do it on
myself does that happen to you
[Music]
that is not the path to building a
movement you know you can have a great
little solo business for yourself but
that's not how you change the world
that's not how you realize your
potential it's not how you have the
impact that you know you're capable of
having you know you have to have people
around you if you've got a big mission
if you don't have a big mission that's
just
it's just you cool go for it but if
you've got a big mission then it needs
to be team and that becomes a skill set
that you have to pick up and learn
and so leadership for me is again caring
about people as humans more than caring
about them winning with you it's about
discovering what they want to learn and
grow and improve at and you being a
vehicle to help them do that
and it's surprising how often you can
find things that support them and
support you not all the time I remember
having one guy in my team who his dream
was to be a baker
like well I I don't have an interest in
opening up a bake shop right but
ultimately you should you should leave
us and go do your passion because
because I can't help you inside of this
job
until I open a bake shop that can really
support you in what you want to do and
so even though he wanted to stay he was
staying more out of fear and insecurity
than actually doing something he was
deeply passionate about so I gave him
till the end of the year if it was you
know summer give him to the end of the
year to okay you're as of the end of the
year you you're out and you have to go
find a job I love you but you have to go
find something that is
in line with your dream because you
staying here is is safe and it's
actually squashing your dreams
you have to go do your thing and so you
know he had to go and move on and was
appreciative for it and giving him time
not like okay you're fired next week
and then you have other people though
and usually you can find something
inside of what they care about so the
the amount of people who I've met on my
team who then they want to learn graphic
design or they want to learn Photoshop
or they want to learn uh copywriting or
they want to learn how to come up with
good titles or they want to learn
better communication skills if they want
to learn they have their lists of like
the things that they want to learn
it's like cool as long as there's
something that we've got
that can help you with that some kind of
program some project something that can
also bring value to the company then
let's do it because when people are
working on the things that they feel
like they're growing in and they're
learning in
they're gonna
it's just a good thing to do because
it's it's from the heart you know and
when they feel connected to your heart
everybody's happier and more productive
but it's also just good business
strategy if you want to just put your
Exo business strategy hat on it's it's
great this is how Karma becomes
practical if somebody's engaged and they
feel like they're learning and they're
growing and they're improving you're
going to get the best of them versus you
have to feel bored and stuck and
learning nothing new right that's what
most people do in their jobs and
honestly the bar for leadership is so
low
it's so low most people wake up and
drive to that job that they hate so all
you have to do to be honest to be their
best boss is probably just to not be a
bad boss you don't have to be a great
boss you just have to not not be a bad
boss you need to treat somebody
like a normal human being and actually
have a little bit of care and compassion
and curiosity to see them win in life
you do that you're already probably
their best boss of all time I think
that's a pretty low standard but it's a
great starting point
to then be able to say hey no I want I
want this person to have come out of my
organization whether that's in a month
or year 10 years from now a better human
because they were with us and it's
totally possible
it's just a mindset shift
that
these people are on your team
because they have something to prove as
well and they want to learn and it's not
just about you saving your time and
dumping stuff off of your plate and
giving it to somebody else so it can be
all delegated away
it's that you are a leader
and you care about people
want to see them win and you're
responsible for making sure that they
get pushed outside their comfort zone
you got a big mission inside you
a huge mission
and you can't do this alone
and you may not have the skills yet
to be the leader that you want to be
maybe not yet
but you've got a big heart and honestly
that's the biggest skill that you ever
need you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you will sing in the shower but
you won't sing on the street corner why
because of other people because they may
see you because they may laugh at you
because they may say look at that person
they're so dumb right you're not afraid
of failing not not just by yourself
you're afraid of failing and who is
going to watch and so that becomes
really important because it now means
you're living your life based off of
other people's expectations and
judgments and maybe that's
people in your own family maybe that's
people you know maybe that's your mom or
maybe that's random people you're afraid
of the Judgment of unknown YouTube
commenters and leaving some kind of
feedback on your video telling you how
much you suck right we're afraid of the
people that we care deeply about in
their perspective and opinions on us and
we're also afraid of the the people who
we don't know yet who are just out there
in the world on the internet who might
come and leave negativity on whatever
you're going to be creating so you're
not actually afraid of failing you'll do
it all the time but it's failing and who
is going to see us fail and so there's a
lot to unpack inside of that let's start
with
what is your big goal what do you want
to accomplish what mission are you on
who are you trying to serve who are you
trying to help and in order for you to
go off and accomplish those things and
serve to your highest capability you're
going to have to do things that will be
scary where you're going to risk failure
right if you are never risking any kind
of failure then you're living your life
so small and so safe that you don't like
your life
if there's nothing in your calendar in
the next month that you are excited by
the that your heart's getting you're
you're scared really you're nervous
right you're like oh my gosh that
thing's happening if there's nothing in
your calendar that's like that you don't
like your life that that's honestly most
people
you're just photocopying your same life
over and over and over and over and over
again that's what most people wake up
and do I'm sitting here in the Costco
parking lot right like most most people
you just wake up and you're photocopying
the same day you had yesterday and last
week and last year that's not a life
so you have to be willing to risk some
kind of failure which would potentially
risk other how other people see you and
judge you I used to not be able to
record videos like this I mean the first
video I ever recorded in public
was I was walking down the street at my
old house and I was challenged by my
agent he said you have to record videos
in public like Steve mcfeet is in public
are you crazy I can barely make videos
at home I'm gonna now make them in
public like you have to do it like okay
great so I'm walking down the street
carrying my big video camera at the time
and
I made sure I picked a really quiet
section of the street where nobody was
usually outside because it made me feel
like I was recording the video and doing
the task but there was nobody around so
I wasn't really doing the task and I
remember there was a male male uh male
woman who was dropping off mail and as
soon as I saw her and I felt like I was
in auditory range of her then I pulled
the camera down
and then as I passed her I started
filming again
it's like I did the assignment Steve
look I filmed outside I didn't really do
the assignment but why because I'm
afraid of of a male woman's opinion of
me like she doesn't even care about me
she's she's living her life doing her
thing
and so something like this now I'm
sitting here in a parking lot filming
and people are walking by and some
people are watching like what's this guy
doing you keep going you just keep
making because fear of other people's
judgments cannot be a good enough reason
for you to play small not anymore and if
you want to do great things most of the
people judging you don't like their own
lives and any judgment they have of you
is just a reflection of self
so there's a couple of hacks that I've
used to be able to get through it that
might serve you
number one is studying successful people
and anytime you study successful people
you find out that they failed along the
way to their success
a lot of times you may just see on the
surface just their accomplishments and
list of what they've done and all that
and it could feel
um imposing you know how are they so
perfect and I suck and I have all these
fears and insecurities but if you look
deeper into their story and maybe watch
some of their interviews or videos
you'll see that they struggled a lot and
they had multiple failures on their path
to success and I used to before my
channel came out I used to read stories
of different famous entrepreneurs and
how they got started and you know the
kind of zero to one story because it
made me feel like
it was possible
that looking at Warren Buffett now is
crazy you know it's like he's done so
much you can't relate but how do you go
from zero to one and what did he
struggle with and where did he fail that
was inspiring to say hey okay if he
could get through that
now me decades later with a lot more
opportunity and technology and resources
and I could do that you know I could do
something similar so that inspired me to
to get out of my cocoon and to be around
people who are doing amazing things
inspired me to want to go off and do
more it's also why I make videos like
this so that you can learn from Warren
Buffett and all the people that we
profile and because I think the more
that you're around that
the more you'll win I don't know Warren
Buffett personally you probably don't
maybe you do maybe you can text him and
ask for advice I can't not yet but I can
watch his videos and I can learn from
him and I can get better and I can
improve Myself by being around him and
the more that I watch his videos the
more I can think like him just a little
bit and and that's important because
that shifts you forward so being around
more successful people will will shift
you towards success even if they are
virtual through through a computer
screen through videos podcasts books Etc
the second thing is
teaching myself that I do difficult
things
and I think that's really important
because we've accepted fear as a good
enough reason for you not to do the
thing you've accepted other people's
opinions as a good enough reason for you
not to do the thing my trigger words I
call them play bigger triggers you come
up with the triggers that will allow you
to play bigger so if I say scary
difficult or hard then I go off and do
it because I want to be the person who
does the things that are scary difficult
or hard to myself and that's why I still
make videos that's why I write books and
speak on stage and find all of those
things incredibly scary difficult and
hard
so what is it for you and when you can
stop accepting scary difficult or hard
as a good enough reason like I want to
do it but I'm scared okay well that's
not a good enough reason you've already
set you've pre-decided that that's not a
good enough reason so you have to go up
and do the thing it's a scary difficult
heart and you say it you write it you
think it you tell somebody else it as
long as that is the reason for you to
put the brakes on your life it's not a
good enough reason anymore it has to be
something stronger than scary difficult
or hard otherwise you have to go and
take action and you start to teach
yourself that you are the kind of person
who takes on things that are scary
typical of the heart so number one was
being around successful people
and and study them and learn from them
and get mentorship from them even if
it's just through a video number two is
that you do difficult things and then
number three is
focus on service
and if you understand that the thing
that you're afraid to do
is not just for you it's for other
people right if you're an entrepreneur
you're trying to create a business it's
not just for you there's sure there's
selfish goals of I want to I want to
make money and provide for my family and
live a great life Etc but above that
needs to be service and helping others
that you're creating something that's
going to bring value to other people
that it's not just about you making
money but you're providing a real
service something really valuable to
other people that's going to make their
life better if I'm making videos it's
not just about me and numbers on the
channel it's about it's about you and
hopefully for for one of you watching
this video it has a big impact today
when I speak on stage or write the Books
it's not about me it's about who I can
help serve and whenever you can deeply
connect to who you can help serve
at least for me it gives me the courage
to go off and do the thing if I'm
terrified to speak on stage
I'll often look behind the curtain at
the audience and I'll try to find a
couple people it's like I'm doing it for
that person I'm doing it for him I'm
doing for her I've got a message that I
can share that can help them and that
gives me the confidence and the courage
to go do the thing because we'll show up
for other people more than we'll show up
for ourselves and so when you can tie
what you're doing to other people to
Value to service to helping them it'll
give you more confidence and courage to
go off and do the thing that you need to
do and so I call that the the push and
the hug so
the I do difficult things I do scary
things is the push like get out get out
there and do this Carmichael let's go
and the service is the hug like hey I'm
not I'm not doing this just for me I'm
doing it for for all the people out
there as well and some days you need
more of the hug some days you need more
of the push
and you just lean in on what you feel
you need most you know there are some
days when pushing yourself harder is not
the answer you need a hug and there's
some days where hugging yourself more is
not the answer you need to push
and so having a self-awareness and now
okay I need the push right now or I need
the hug right now and then going off and
doing that will give you the momentum
that you need
failure
failure is gonna happen
and the biggest failure again is that
the fear of other people seeing you fail
and as long as you live your life by the
expectations of other people you will
live small forever
and if you can flip it to say I'm doing
this to help others I'm doing this
because
I want to live a great life and I'm
doing this because I do difficult things
when you can make that shift happen you
start to accomplish your goals what
stops us from chasing our obsession is
the Judgment that it's wrong we feel
that it's wrong to pour so much time and
energy and effort into something
especially if it's not working out and
paying dividends and results it's yes
the people around us telling us that
what are you doing that's crazy stop
doing it but it's also us it's our own
voice in our own head saying can I do
this am I wasting my time is this thing
even worth doing and then what ends up
happening is you regret not taking the
action right we don't regret the things
that we do often It's usually the things
that we don't do the actions untuck the
goals that you had that you are too
afraid to do something on
and that Obsession that we felt was
wrong think of this in my life I used to
judge myself a lot on this and I would
get obsessed like one of the things that
I think now is a core strength of mine
is I get obsessed on something then it
has to happen I was at an event and uh
it was a YouTube event and there was a
really really big famous guy runs a
bunch of events pretty well known and I
was on him for you to start a YouTube
channel did you got to start a YouTube
channel and I was just on him on him on
him on him fast forward to today is
about three years ago he's got a YouTube
channel he's got six figures and
subscribers
um and he's on my mind because I was
texting him some thumbnail ideas this
morning and I just I was on him I
couldn't let it go like this has to
happen you you need to do this and it
just felt right and that energy and that
conviction is one of the things that
helped move the needle and you've got
ideas and energy and great things in you
and products you want to create and
services you want to launch and people
that you want to serve and help and it
and trust it and listen to it the indeed
the thing that's in your heart that is
this little it's a it's a it's a muscle
to develop the courage to follow the
obsession because
a lot of our brain takes over and tells
us to be safe and be practical and do
the smart thing and make sure that
you're paying your bills and all of that
and yes of course you have to learn how
to pay your bills
but where we taught the courage muscle
where we taught the obsession muscle
where we taught to to you've got this
dream that is noble and worthy where are
we taught to actually follow through on
and at least do something about it so
over the years it's taken me a long time
and and the goal with this video is to
try to help it
not take as long for you over the years
I used to judge myself for wanting
something
and just thinking about it constantly
and sometimes those ideas lead to
long-term projects I look at my YouTube
channel how my main channel it's been 13
years
13 years
[Music]
oh you know 13 000 videos something like
that not all of them are public
how well it's because because I'm
obsessed I want to I want to bring more
value I want to create more content I
want to impact more entrepreneurs it's a
how do you how do you stay consistent on
something because I want to do it
because I'm obsessed about it because I
feel like it's going to matter even at
the beginning when I had 25 subscribers
in my first year and 7 000 subscribers
after five years like how do you keep
going well I was obsessed with trying to
make content that I thought would help
some people and that's been a long-term
Obsession there are some that are a lot
shorter term
um I remember I was on writing my book
your one word also built to serve both
of my books
were flowing through me and there was
every reason why I shouldn't do it your
one word I finished writing the book on
my cruise I was on vacation with my wife
and we're enjoying our vacation and it
was flowing through it's like I need to
I need to do this and so while she slept
I I wrote my book and while she uh went
to a show or or did some something at
the spa I finished writing the book we
still did the excursions and saw the
cities together but the second part of
the cruise I was I was just in it was
flowing through me I had to get this
thing done otherwise I know I'm going to
regret it if I build the serve I wrote
it when I was on my tour in 2019 and I
did not have time to write a book I did
not have time I mean I was behind that
everything where we're traveling every
four days to New City I'm presenting it
just I did not have time to do this
I did not have time and yet it was
flowing through me and like I'm obsessed
I have to get this done I have to have
to have to have to get this done
and
with experience and age and time I've
learned to lean in on those things
instead of Judge them where typically
what happens is you come with a good
idea you think it's great it has a lot
of potential and then you immediately
judge it to say well I can't do that I'm
not worthy I'm not good enough I don't
have the skills I don't have the money
uh why am I still spending all this time
on thinking about some idea that that I
could never do we instantly judge it and
maybe you do a little bit of work on it
you start trying and you taste and you
test and you explore a little bit and
then and then what happens if you don't
get immediate results you wake up the
next day or the next week or the next
month and say see I knew you couldn't do
it
you're crazy why would you think you
could do this and instantly we talk
ourselves down from it
and
what I've learned to try to do and I'm
still
working on it is to listen to that
intuition and listen to that gut and and
it's right and it's Noble and great
ideas flow through you and stop judging
them and so the process I use
is one that great ideas flow through me
so just believe the great ideas flow
through you this is how you eliminate
the overthinking and and your brain
getting in the way you come with a great
idea your brain gets in the way how do
you get out of that great ideas flow
through you just trust a great idea the
fact that it came to you as long as
you're in a positive optimistic energy
you know surveying state if you're
feeling jealous or rage or you know if
somebody cuts you off in in line them in
my car right now we're parked but if
somebody cuts you off when you're you're
upset maybe maybe the idea that comes to
you is not a good idea but if you're
feeling positive and encouraged and
optimistic and and serving and want to
help and an idea comes to you trust the
great ideas flow through you just tell
yourself great it is flow through me and
that at least gives me the courage to
stop overthinking and start doing
something step number two is just get
started start I call it the two percent
difference what's the first two percent
we waste our best energy on trying to
plan out 100 of where this company or
idea business is going to grow that's
not the way to do it you'll you'll never
plan it at 100 you have no idea what's
going to happen with this thing and so
instead of spending your best energy
this is the problem you spend your best
energy oh this could be like this we
could do that oh yeah here's how it
could work out your energy where you
feel confident and bold you spend your
best energy on research and planning
instead of doing something and research
and planning are important but it can't
be the first step because you're again
wasting your best energy you wake up the
next day you feel like oh I can't do
this so instead your best energy the
first step needs to be the first two
percent you're doing something you're
calling somebody you're booking
something you're creating something when
I had an idea to start a podcast I I
messaged my friend Mark and said we're
gonna start a podcast and he said when
tonight what do you mean when tonight
when I'm back from my tour in a month
and a half no we're starting it tonight
but we don't have the gear what are we
going to talk about and we'll figure it
out I'm going to get back to we're going
to drive to my Airbnb and we're gonna
we're gonna launch our podcast together
tonight it has to happen tonight or it's
not going to happen
right that that becomes a process super
important and step number three is just
expect a suck at the start expect to
suck at the start we expect to be great
for whatever reason at the beginning of
when we're doing our thing right we
expect to be great don't expect to be
great expect to suck expect the first
thing to be terrible for it not to work
out
cheers it's not gonna work out not as
you plan not at the beginning you don't
get on a bike and just ride it you don't
make a video and just crush it right it
doesn't mean that you suck as a person
you just don't have the skill set yet
and by practicing and trying and tasting
and testing you'll get a little bit
better and when you start something and
you expect to be great and then you're
not great you quit
but when you start something and you
expect it to be terrible then anything
above terrible is progress his momentum
is a win and celebrate that celebrate
the fact that you took a step celebrate
the fact that you recorded a video
celebrate the fact that you wrote the
first page in your book celebrate the
fact that you you launched your first
episode of a podcast even though you
don't know what questions to talk about
what questions to ask the formatting all
of that stuff that doesn't matter you
started momentum you celebrate the
momentum and expect the results to suck
at the beginning and if you keep going
you'll learn the skill to get better at
the thing so it's okay to be obsessed
it's okay there's there's a great idea
inside you that you know you want to
work on that you know you need to do
be obsessed on it start small create
something right now apply the two
percent difference trust the great ideas
flow through you expect to expect a suck
at the beginning
and make it because otherwise you look
back on your life at this moment and say
I could have done something back then
and I wish I had
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from John Assaraf
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there a lot of athletes
have this term around the a game and
showing up and doing their absolute best
mentally emotionally physically
spiritually Etc and it got me thinking
about do you even know what your A game